benefit 2.0 is thriving my life right
now is just so amazing the pair is going
strong and by the looks of it inspiring
each other to do better it's great a
source tells et that jen brings out
ben's best self quote jen is so
supportive and is always pumping him up
and saying how talented he is you can
tell he just is so positive and
appreciative of how great things are
going right now i'd be lying if i didn't
say i was thrilled and excited
the source adds it's taken affleck many
ups and downs to get to this place i was
very lucky not only are they flourishing
as a couple but jlo's work ethic has
been a huge influence on the oscar
winner you know that's the joy for me
quote he loves jennifer and says she
makes him a better person and motivates
him to work hard he wants to take care
of her even though she doesn't need him
to that is just the type of guy he is
you know what can i say e.t recently
caught up with ben at the premiere of
his latest film the tender bar where he
joked about arriving a little underdress
next to his lady what if i rolled up
here you know what i mean it would be
okay because the way your woman looked
today i mean my god you came with the
damn goddess there you go well then i
should probably wear my shorts next time
and ben's been busy he also recently
starred in the last duel alongside his
longtime friend matt damon and when e.t
spoke with the boston native at the
premiere he couldn't help but smile over
his pal find in love with jen again it's
great
it's wonderful and i'm just happy to see
see my friend really happy we couldn't
agree more matt this rekindled romance
continues to give us all the feels you
guys want to get used to seeing us again
as for the triple threat she seems
equally smitten check out this pic she
posted on instagram last month sipping
out of a b mug you know b as in ben and
in november the marry me star told the
today show that a future marriage isn't
out of the question i mean i you know me
i'm a romantic i always have been i
still believe in happily ever after for
sure stay tuned on that one but until
then we'll leave you with all these
super adorable photos of the couple that
we truly cannot get enough of
you